[Music]
[Laughter]
feelings of rage no a normal amount of
rage i wouldn't say something asleep was
the air horn really necessary for comedy
absolutely it's all for science
just for his own comedy multi-year
journey you're about to embark on i love
how he did like almost like the free
throw right you're just like jordan like
no look
mickey
swish
[Laughter]
for sure
yo she's nailing this you have something
pissed
i like this trailer a lot more than the
first one
so i'm clearly nailing it at all these
things
thunderclap the clap you want to go she
clapped my life as a lawyer i i respect
that
he doesn't mean that
i love that they break the fourth wall
like i know it's
gonna be so much fun
more and more eccentric superhumans are
coming out of the woodwork there's your
boy let's go
tony stark 2.0 vision for them and i
want the she-hulk to be the face of
jennifer wallace
chair for music conflict of interest
this man tried to kill my cousin bruce
yeah that's quite all right oh he hates
burns so much people only care because
i'm representing him
i think they care because they're like
hey that girl's green
hey
[Music]
i'm not proud of this
i am proud of you miss walters oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
you know that friend you had in high
school
who was way cooler than you were
attractive got all the attention from
everyone
hello i was that friend
jealous
i think he actually is jealous
[Music]
thank you kevin feige you treat me too
well jesus christ welcome back to new
rock stars she-hulk released a new
trailer at comic-con for its nine
episode season coming august 17th and we
are gonna break down everything in this
trailer the appearances of daredevil the
book of ashanti and our man frog man
joining us today frog man let's go frog
squad stand up right now he's flying
guys he has a jet pack my life is
complete
my god now as this becomes our she-hulk
after show i'm not sure yet what uh call
to arms we're going to do at the
beginning of episode but for now we're
going to try out holy holy [ __ ]
[Laughter]
words this is inside marvel new
rockstars weekly marvel reaction show
comic con gave us so much news about
marvel phases five and six but closing
out phase four will be she-hulk and
wakana forever and from august through
october this show will be our she-hulk
after show so we wanted to do a preview
episode here to tag team this trailer
breakdown i'm eric voss i'm here with
empty
i am so ready for frogman season and
also she-hulk season of course because i
love she-hulk but frogmen season is here
i cannot wait to see how jennifer
walters helps him out of a legal trouble
because uh he's gonna get himself into
legal trouble he's gonna he's gonna
fight people i mean is this really just
a frogman after show like should we just
change it to what the frog i think so
what the [ __ ] i think about the frog
would be amazing i would love it what
the [ __ ] so just a quick reminder
she-hulk of course nine episode series
following jennifer walters cousin of
bruce banner she becomes she-hulk she's
an attorney and an avenger who spends
most of her time in hulk form she's
known for really her meta humor her
sexual empowerment her badassery this
season is gonna be formatted as a
half-hour legal comedy totally akin to
shows like ali mcbeal or maybe the
netflix jessica jones you know with the
case of the week structure that
highlights different aspects of the
marvel world she gets her hulk powers in
the comics from a blood transfusion from
her cousin bruce but in the show we have
yet to really see how exactly she will
acquire these
jennifer walters is an attorney who has
accidentally taken in the hulk's blood
so let's break down the she-hulk trailer
detail by detail i found uh 20 details
specifically uh that i want to talk
about each of them with you empty um so
really we open with this moment of hulk
blaring an air horn to hulk out his
cousin jen walters as she wakes up and
he reveals that she reverts to gen form
when she sleeps telling us something new
about she-hulk's power set mt
why do you think that's the case why did
she go back to gen 4 when she sleeps
it's actually really interesting thing
because like it seems like jen has a lot
more control over her hulk powers than
bruce and i feel like bruce is sort of
getting jealous of that in the trailer
um but like it seems that you know
rather with bruce like his alter ego is
just like he takes control whenever he
wants to sort of and he has to struggle
with that but with her it seems more
like a choice it's like a conscious
decision all right if i'm awake i'm
going to choose to become the green
version of myself because i like this
better than me but better than my my
regular version so i think it's just
more so more of control over her
over that other side of herself than
bruce um because like she probably had
less gamma radiation exposure than bruce
had because like in the comics it was a
blood transfusion that changes her into
she-hulk whereas with with bruce with
bruce banner he got that full dose of
radiation which caused him to go full
hulk out so i think it's probably just
like a difference of dosage here that uh
makes it more manageable for her but
what do you think can i drop a theory on
you right now it's too early
now
theory corner okay so wong shows up in
this right talks about the precipice
talks about the
the uh book of vashanti what did strange
the multiverse madness teach us about
what we do when we dream we visit the
alternate lives of our alternate selves
across the multiverse true baby
consciousness going into a multiverse
where she doesn't have the scammer
radiated blood is why her consciousness
reverts her back to gen form while she
sleeps
that would make a lot of sense i feel
with jen's character because like i feel
like she really doesn't like herself and
like she doesn't like her actual
non-hulk self so like i feel like she
would have maybe nightmare dreams about
being normal this is like her brain is
just like all right let's be normal now
because like we're having our nightmares
of being normal uh picking the
multiverse so like yeah no i love that
theory a lot a lot a lot like i don't i
don't know how likely it is i just i i
love this idea that maybe the multiverse
has some uh important impact on
why she hulk is exactly the way she is
in this show
i'm probably setting my i'm already
pointing to the stands with a baseball
bat i don't think we're gonna get there
i though
but a boy can dream i actually haven't
more thoughts on what how that might
manifest but um i just like how in this
opening imagery we're already seeing
some improved aspects of she-hulk's
design you know they have some more
green in her hair and i think really
this moment works better not necessarily
because like uh because they put more
time into rendering her face and you
know by the way i think everyone should
read the vulture piece on uh
the relationship between marvel and
their vfx artists we're learning some
interesting stuff about that person
that's great but um but i think what
works here and this is what i wanna i
hope we see more of in the mcu is it's
fueled by the emotion her anger gets the
spotlight and it's it's a joke in the
moment and we're willing to just go with
it because we're connecting with the
character in this moment it's just so
funny to hear a character scream the
words a normal amount of rage it's just
like so funny and so because we're
laughing and connecting we're there in
that moment we're less scrutinizing and
in fact run this experiment with
yourself when you're watching everybody
who's watching this
re-watch that clip and then just pause
and then once you're paused and you're
taken out of the joke then you start to
just naturally scrutinize the vfx more
than you would as you're just watching
it and it's just reminded everyone
watching
just
don't worry about pausing it leave the
pausing frame by frame to me and mt yeah
we'll do that for you
you just sit back and watch and enjoy it
and experience the character's emotions
vicariously and i think you're going to
enjoy it a lot more that way that's how
it's meant to be processed yeah and like
the cg isn't even that bad i feel like
people are less overblown and like
people have to also keep in mind that
jennifer walters wears green makeup so
like her face is not going to look like
the hulks she's purposely putting on
green makeup to look different so going
on green foundation yeah yeah it's
different it's different so there's less
detail and i think it was a quarter crew
uh fellas who actually pointed that out
that um female faces in media in general
are are have more makeup on them so like
the indentations that our brains
associate with being more lifelike are
not as visible on a woman's face in
general on screen next we get this uh
bolder throwing contest between the
cousins and i really like specifically
the gesture of the way hulk doesn't like
throwing a a free throw you know he does
like the
yeah the larry bird or whatever the hook
no the uh uh uh
uh kareem abdul-jabbar hook you know
i watched winnie time i know basketball
but the detail i think is interesting is
hulk says this is a multi-year journey
you're about to embark on and this line
just feels like a promise that she-hulk
is going to join the avengers in
upcoming events like kang dynasty and
secret wars events what do you think mt
i definitely think that you know that's
that's definitely the goal like shields
for sure gonna join the avengers down
the line but i think that you know him
saying that was bruce's intention like
he wanted her to be a hero and like i
don't think that jen wants to be a hero
i think she wants to be a lawyer and i
think that um throughout this season
we're going to see that her her constant
interaction with all these super powered
people can it's kind of gonna force her
to be a hero even though she doesn't
want to be and um you know we see that
uh bruce banner's just sort of like i
guess you could be a lawyer if you don't
if you want to be a hero it's just like
yeah like i can totally see bruce
wanting a sidekick or like like a
partner to fight crime with him because
like he just he doesn't want to feel
like a beast alone you know and like jen
just wants to own her stuff as a lawyer
which i don't blame her like why would
you want to be a hero in the mcu it's
terrible
what do you think yeah um no i like that
interpretation a lot empty and i think
immediately that is the context of this
scene is uh he's kind of putting her
through avengers boot camp and she's
deciding whether or not this is right
for her uh but i think there is a wink
to us here like of all the new avengers
that are joining the avengers lineup i
don't really know what the lineup's
going to look like in kang dynasty and
secret wars the fact that daniel destin
[ __ ] is directing kang dynasty uh
implies that shung chi's probably going
to be part of that lineup i would
imagine um but is it is you know kamala
khan gonna play with them or is she
gonna be playing with the young avengers
is is anthony mackie captain america
going to be a part of that lineup
probably is bucky gonna be part of it
like who who's going to make up the
avengers and are we going to like them
as much as we did the infinity saga
avengers um either way the fact that
like presumably the fantastic four and
the x-men are also going to be part of
that um i think either way we're going
to be happy with it
but it's it puts a lot of weight on
these shows to make us fall in love with
these characters right away you know
yeah like for sure i feel like these
shows are introducing a lot of like
really fun side characters that like
they're they're gearing up for a an
avengers type situation like you know
your frogmans and like your titanias and
like you're all them like they're gonna
shove them all into an avengers movie
and i'm wondering if like because we
have so many new marvel heroes that like
we might have like a separate avenger
situation where like we have one
avengers movie where like we are dealing
with like
the half of the avengers where the the
another avengers movie we're dealing
with the other half of the avengers i
don't know um but secret wars seems like
it's going to be obviously a huge
multiverse event so probably not like
yeah secret war is going to bring
everyone into the sandbox for sure
literally i think you're like somebody
everybody
everybody everybody yeah uh the uh i
think i love this idea that maybe when
the adults have to go fight kang
through the time stream you might have
the young avengers left on earth having
to deal with something else right and
like kate bishop could lead that you
know yeah i really want to see that
scenario you just want to see anything
with kate bishop yeah i mean i'm biased
i know i'm biased i love bishop but like
i do want to see like the the young
avengers or like the west coast avengers
really grow into their own and have
their own conflict that they have to
fight and prove themselves like yeah
we're just as good as like the the old
heads like we can do this yeah uh for
sure let's move on to the third detail
uh we actually pointed this out in the
first trailer bruce tries to provoke
jen's power by putting her in this
torture chamber with buzz saws that are
labeled with stark industries that now
you can see the school diesel she
flattens them with their hand i just
love the way that metal smooshes right
but i just want to know mt for what
reason does stark industries design
these buzzsaws they're a weapons
manufacturer does this proof that stark
industries was involved with torture
this has kwitch and beck all over it
this is when quincy back was part of
stark industries he was like check out
this new invention i made tony was like
you're unhinged you're fine
but no like that's a really good
question i don't i couldn't even tell
you like maybe it was designed to maybe
like contain bruce should he ever hulk
out or like maybe it was like his one of
his first attempts to stop bruce but
like i don't know that's a weird torture
chokey device the joke is like a matilda
reference yes it looks like a jokey um
it's just as intimidating
it totally is it's a reminder that
pre-phase one tony stark was involved in
war crimes and torture
he should be put to death
he did it himself he did society a favor
okay i think
my at least second favorite moment from
this trailer the thunderclap yes uh and
i love hulk doing this in the comics we
only have seen this once in the mcu the
2008 film with ed norton when he's
fighting abomination but when joss
whedon redesigned the character for
2012's avengers they kind of did away
with those classic aspects of the
character now but what i love about this
when you pause on the clap there is a
green glow
now mt
normally the thunderclap is just
supposed to be hulk's hands are so
strong or they move so fast that they
kind of
create a sonic boom and that's what it
is but the fact that this glow is green
makes me wonder could there be a release
of radiation that fuels the hundred that
fuels the thunderclap i love that
observation i love that a lot and i
think that that's very likely the case
here because like i like the clap the
hulk's claps are definitely strong but
like there has to be an extra kick that
makes it like super extra powerful
because
women don't blow like that
exactly a little something like that
but yeah i i definitely think that
there's a gamma radiation in those uh in
those thunder claps for sure
it's a good oh man that's such a good uh
good good spot we'll be talking a lot
about again just trust me and mt to
pause these things
[Laughter]
okay fifth detail there's this moment
where jen breaks the fourth wall and
let's roll the clip if you want to go
back to your life as a lawyer i i
respect that
he doesn't mean that
okay i consider this a fleabag moment
and indeed the show's producers
confirmed that they actually drew from
phoebe waller bridge's amazing comedy
series flea bag you gotta watch this
show she did like one season like
several years ago and then like we
didn't think that there would be a
second season and then like six years
later she does another season and it's
even better and she all breaks the
fourth wall in the comics as well but i
just like how visually they're kind of
using the exact blocking and the timing
that phoebe waller bridge did on that
show uh specifically with the way hulk
also turns around wondering who she's
talking to it's a recreation of the
wildest moment in fleabag that scared
the hell out of me when andrew scott who
plays the sexy priest on the show
reveals that he can also see when
fleabag talks to the camera let's roll
the clip he's been lying asking what is
that
what
the thing that you're doing it's like
you disappear
what are you not telling me
nothing tell me what's going on
underneath nothing tell me come on don't
tell me nothing
no stop being so churchy but i want to
ask you mt do you think jen's breaking
of the fourth wall could be part of what
i was referring to earlier a multiverse
syndrome condition
and that this could be a specific trait
that she shares with deadpool a kind of
mutation aspect when deadpool enters the
mcu because the because the multiverse
because incursions have been occurring
she and wade wilson have this ability to
break through the fourth wall and talk
to us or at least from everyone else's
point of view they're just like they're
talking to no one right now but they're
actually talking to us i would dig that
a lot i would really dig that like you
know what if like something happens
chemically in your brain that allows you
to
connect with a like a being or an entity
outside of your reality and like i feel
like you know like you said deadpool of
she-hulk and maybe even um gwenpool um
she
breaks the fourth wall as well so like
having that be like oh yeah there's a
scientific explanation sort of for
breaking the fourth wall i think that
would be really fun i i really hope that
that's actually the case because i dig
that a lot yeah i mean uh i what i love
about doing this or one of the many
things i love about doing what we do is
like when these shows start to bring in
details and parallels from other shows
that new rockstar subscribers might not
have even heard of or watched it gives
us an opportunity to shout those out and
like
i would love to do a series just
breaking down um
non-marvel movies but having marvel
directors and actors you know like doing
a series on taiwa tt's other movies that
have nothing to do with the mcu or like
uh that movie
uh this movie wind river that has jeremy
renner and elizabeth olsen in it and
this is after age of ultron came out but
like jeremy renner plays like a local
guide on an indian reservation where
there has been a sexual assault and
elizabeth olsen plays like a federal
agent who has to investigate it and it's
like one of my favorite movies that's
come out in the past eight years and it
has nothing to do with marvel and i
would love to break it down and uh i
recommend it to everybody um
because there are other great movies out
there with these talented people that
impossible it's only the mcu
just kidding
okay let's move on to the sixth detail
jen works for the legal firm glk and h
which i pointed out in past videos
stands for goodman lieber kurtzberg in
holloway named after marvel comics
founders martin goodman stan lee lieber
and jack kirby born
kurtzberg um but holden holloway is the
still active partner on this firm that
we see in this show uh he's playing
jen's boss
there's nothing really discussed there i
just kind of want to tell people the
history there it's a good detail we get
a new shot of frog man flying away with
some rocket propelled boots and mt i
give you the floor what do you want to
tell us about frogman dude frogman's the
truth man that's all you need to know
like frogman is going to be mcu's
kickass like if you enjoyed the kickass
films with uh matthew vaughn like that's
all i see frogman he's a dude that like
he sees spider-man and he's like yo i
want to be a hero too why can't i do it
and so he just puts out a frog themed
costume and he goes out in front it
fights crime and spider-man keeps trying
to get him to not do that because he's
got to get himself killed um in the
comics he's a lot more ridiculous which
is why i love him but in the mcu it
seems like kevin feige and the
showrunners here are making him super
badass like making him sort of like a
power rangers ass give him a power
rangers s suit give him a jet pack and
like having him fly around like iron man
like this i feel like they hopefully
have some big plans for frogman in the
future i need to see a frogman tv show
um in my lifetime before i die uh
because i just feel like this is a
really badass character that we're gonna
be introduced to in this show i cannot
wait
yes i'm so glad that they brought them
in it's gonna be a lot of fun all right
the eighth detail a prospective client
jumps out of a window and then lands
safely because he's super powered on a
higman security car now there are two
details here higman is a nod to an art
department crew member kyle hickman way
to get yourself in the mcu there kyle
and then this actor is actually dave
pasquazzi legendary improv comedian and
the same actor who played the twilight
major domo in the book of boba fett
remember this guy who is just spitting
acid whenever he could be with his
passive aggression to boba fett like oh
i will have to get back to you on that
and he scoots away in his speed
this guy i can't get enough of davis
crazy he's so funny and so talented okay
so then there's this moment where
there's a judge price who transforms
into a kathleen elf and this
transformation looks a lot like the
cloaking magic that loki uses where it
just kind of bleeds over their body uh
and if this is a trial that jen is
working the whole thing could actually
be a sham you know with with all parts
of it uh shape-shifted um now mt do you
think asgardian witches or sorcerers
could tie into this series i think
for sure um as guardians will show up in
this series because like we as we saw in
thor 11 thunder like asgard seems to be
a pla like a home for not just as
guardians but for all people across the
galaxy across the universe like
different types of aliens um as you know
korg sort of mentioned at the end of uh
the third movie is like hey it's gonna
be a haven for all peoples and so like
since like earth has aliens and since
like the the end of avengers end game
introduce more aliens through the
portals like they have ravagers and all
that the earth is just filled with all
sorts of
new people and i feel like asgardian
witches and sorcerers could definitely
tie into the types of people that show
up into
jen's line of work i love that theory mt
that like someone might have like fled
or left new asgard and that could be
some of the uh the political turmoil the
drama that like a valkyrie has to deal
with like there's people who like i
don't want to live in norway it's too
cold up here so they move to la and then
they get into all kinds of trouble with
their powers that they have right so
tenth detail as jen gets gawked at in a
law firm one attorney just has a wall
full of comics covers it's kind of hard
to see which comics they are i just
thought it's it's always interesting to
see comic books show up in the mcu like
you know the kids in the first cap film
are reading the cap comic it's
interesting to see like these character
stories and the avengers legends within
this world all be canonized as these
comics i dig it and like it and it
definitely leaves the room open for
century because in the comics century
has his own comics in the marvel comics
so like i would love to see if a century
one popped up oh i would cry it would be
amazing all right we want to thank some
friends who helped us make this episode
thanks to brooklyn for sponsoring this
episode of inside marvel all this
incredible comic con news has been
heating up our summers luckily for us
brooklyn is here to keep you cool and
living in comfort with their
best-selling bedding loungewear towels
and more brooklyn and gives its
customers hotel level home essentials
they offer everything from snuggly
sheets to cozy towels and robes
loungewear accessories and more by
working directly with suppliers brooklyn
cuts out the luxury markups and passes
those savings back to their customers
and they have new products colors and
patterns all the time for their sheets
towels and robes they even have some
limited edition collections and that
sell out really fast and make your
entire bed feel like the cool side of
the pillow with brooklyn's signature
crisp breathable classic percale sheets
replace your heavy winter bedding with
their lightweight comforters for the
ultimate breezy light as a cloud feel
the smooth long staple cotton will keep
you feeling cool at night and if you're
not sure where to start you can shop
with ease thanks to brooklyn's online
quiz their quiz is the best place to
find a curated list of high quality
products perfectly suited for your
unique preferences so head over to
brooklyn today to keep you cool at home
and on the go all summer long go to
brooklyn.com and use the promo code
inside marvel to get 20 off your
purchase of 100 or more in free shipping
that's r o o k l i n e n dot com and
enter the promo code inside marvel for
twenty dollars off and free shipping but
the news from comic-con is confirmed
that this that the number of mcu phases
isn't the only thing that's growing you
guessed it this episode also brought to
you by blue chew fellas confidence can
take you far in life it can also help in
the bedroom that's where blue chew comes
in blue chew is the unique online
service that delivers the same active
ingredients as viagra and cialis but in
shootable tablets and at a fraction of
the cost you can take them anytime day
or night so you can plan ahead or be
ready for whenever an opportunity arises
the process is simple sign up at
bluetooth.com consult with one of their
licensed medical providers and once you
approve you receive your prescription
within days it's all done online so no
visits to the doctor's office no awkward
conversations and no waiting in line of
the pharmacy bluetooth tablets are made
in the usa and prepared and shipped
direct to your door in a discrete
package so if you could benefit from
some extra confidence when it's time to
perform bluetooth could help help we've
got a special deal for our fans try
bluetooth for you and use our special
promo code of marvel at checkout just
pay the five dollars in shipping that's
bluetooth.com promo code marvel to
receive your first month free visit
bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information and we
thank bluetooth for sponsoring this
podcast empty it's just so funny to be
talking about boners when there's you
with the frog
this is boner fuel eric what do you mean
did you did you make the frog wink
this one was like leaning back i was
like i gotta make sure that it's in
frame i thought you were making him wink
oh yes let's just say
and we want to thank athletic greens for
sponsoring this episode are you looking
for a simple way to get an all-in-one
daily nutritional insurance with one
scoop of eg1 you are absorbing 75 high
quality vitamins minerals whole foods
source superfoods probiotics and
adaptogens to help you start your day
right this special blend of ingredients
supports your gut health your nervous
system and your immune system our very
own tommy bechtol and the rest of the
break room crew started adding ag-1 to
their daily routine and they've been
loving it tommy says it tastes great and
it's easy to drink first thing in the
morning ag-1 supports mental clarity and
alertness as well as better sleep
quality and recovery and for every
purchase they donate to organizations to
get nutritious food to kids in need
including no kid hungry here in the u.s
reclaim your health and arm your immune
system with convenient daily nutrition
it's just one scoop of eg1 and a cup of
water every day to make it easy athletic
greens is going to give you a free one
year supply of immune supporting vitamin
d and five free travel packs with your
first purchase all you have to do is
visit athleticgreens.com marvel again
that's athletic greens.com marvel to
take ownership over your gut help and
pick up the ultimate daily nutritional
insurance all right mt back to the
she-hulk trailer there is an 11th detail
i want to talk to you about jen gets
assigned to represent emil blonte tim
roth aka abomination returning from his
brawl with hulk in the 2008 film which
jen calls a conflict of interest and
then her boss mr holloway just kind of
brushes it off but why do you think
holloway is too cavalier about it do you
think he might have some other agenda or
he's just like here's money
it's just weird that they're partnering
with
the uh
prisoners at the dodc cube facility
uh
what money does emil polanski have to
pay this law firm like what's going on
here i i honestly i feel like they're
sort of um probably following the comics
a little bit and like sort of setting up
the situation where
jen finds out like towards like the end
of the season that the law form law form
that the law firm um only hired her
because she was cousins with an avenger
and that she looks like an avenger and
so like it seems like they're opening up
this new like law firm
dealing with superhuman people they just
need a superhuman representative that
looks good on the company like like
pamphlets and all that stuff like in
marketing so i feel like she's going to
learn that like she her talents are not
really being used in the right way that
she would want and that she's just being
used because she's green and big and
like she's just a lawyer that's just
connected to the hulk i feel like
they're just using her
um in their own way to sort of um get
what they want so they're just like yeah
whatever we don't care if they have a
conflict of interest because like that's
why we hired you that's literally your
purpose that's why you're here um so
that's gonna suck but i feel like
they're going that route but what do you
think do you think you could have some
secret agenda here i do i think you're
right that she's being exploited um i
but i think that the thunderbolts may be
behind i think val could be behind it
she's got some fancy clothes i wouldn't
be surprised if she commissioned this
law firm uh to get uh jennifer walters
in that facility for a specific reason
and they're trying to uh to either get
uh emil blonsky out of his legal
troubles so that he can join the super
team and kind of clear his name that way
um and there's another detail here in
another shot where jen meets with
blonsky and then you can see some
scientists in the background wearing
these glowing green headbands now this
is the facility of the cube we saw it
briefly in ms marvel when the
clandestines pretty easily broke out of
it but it is run by the dodc this place
is shady though and do you think those
headbands might mean this whole cube
room might be flooded with some gamma
radiation to hulk out both jen and emil
in order to test them to make them fight
in some way could that be why jen was
brought in because they're trying to
also recruit her to join the
thunderbolts that would be fun i would
dig it a lot i would really like that a
lot like it'd be really cool to see
um them just sort of like just sort of
sabotage them both it's like yeah we got
those two hulk beings flooded with gamma
radiation let them hulk out let's see
what happens um but i think those like
i'm looking at the the image right now
and like those girls sort of seem like
they don't belong here like those women
in the headbands they seem like they're
like
they seem like like flower headbands
almost like they're they're dressed like
and all white and they have like flower
headbands and like part of me they're
rushing a sorority or something like
that like i can't play tridel
part of me feels like they legally have
to be there because they're concerned
for like the people inside of this
containment facility that like they
struck a deal it's like hey you guys
could watch us
be nice to the abomination he's not
being abused or anything like he's not
being oh
what what if they're like uh uh emil's
manson cult and they're like
behind bars they hired uh the the firm
to to support
i can see that happening it's like they
they made such a stink about a meal but
they were like all right you guys could
come see because like you know it's they
were being okay and so like they seem
like they they seem like they were big
fans i don't know they just by their
body language like it seems like they're
fanatics i mean definitely by tim roth's
body language he's like yeah those are
my
party's over there don't you worry about
it
i don't get conjugal visits yet but
they're walking on it can you hit me
come on love um
okay so on to titanium this is jamila
jamil's character hulk or she-hulk
fights her in this courtroom it's she
looks long-time nemesis uh their power
sets are equally they're equally strong
roughly but we may have seen jamila on
the dodc suspect board back in ms marvel
now
i'm wondering do we think the mcu is
going to use the dodc it's kind of like
the the government body that oversees
these enhanced individuals enhanced
being their code word for mutants and if
uh damila is someone they're looking for
could they establish titania as one of
these mutants i think that that's what
they might be going for i think that
like in the long run it's going to be
revealed that like anybody that's been
that has enhanced powers is a mutant of
some sort and like what what specific
type of mutation you are whether it's
like extreme mutation in human mutation
or like you know
um mind stone mutation etc but that's
that's like has its own those have their
own labels so like i think that titanium
at the end of the day will be a mutant
but whether or not it's going to be an
xg mutant or an inhuman that's that's
meant to be like that that'll be seen
later on but like i feel like she's
definitely a mutant of some sort i i
agree i i think uh the it sounds like
it's pretty casual the way kevin feige
was just cool with uh with kamala khan
being identified as a mutant and the
truth of that is is that like kamala
khan by the comics creators always
wanted to make her mutant but just at
that era in marvel comics they kind of
had to make her an inhuman right uh so
in some ways it was like a homecoming
for the character but i think uh i think
kevin feige is okay with establishing
anyone who has like vaguely defined
power sets who are just humans but
enhanced
go ahead and make him a mutant why not
right and i don't think people are that
attached to like titania or any of these
characters to say like oh she can't be a
mutant like that's what marvel comics
historically has done it's just like you
know half of the marvel comics world or
mutants right it's true and like i feel
like kevin feige has a really unique
opportunity here because like he doesn't
have like that long history of the
comics the long weird like messiness of
like all right we don't want to include
the
the mutants in the comics anymore so
like he can sort of like streamline the
language whereas like in the comics
things have been so complicated there's
mutants there's mutates there's all
sorts of labels and kevin feige just
wants to like really just like make it
simple for everyone so i feel like that
was going to be so much different in
terms of labeling than the marvel comics
there okay 14th detail this is just a
little one that i want to point out on
she-hulk's social media feed one of her
flirty commenters is track suit 22 and
he writes
she-hulk is hot bro yeah this is one of
the track suits from hawkeye who's a fan
i love these guys showing up everywhere
there's a there's a trusted bro moving
truck in the ms marvel closing credits
yes okay now on to some multiverse stuff
wong enters through a sling ring portal
in this footage and he says we answer to
a higher power our universe is at a
precipice and then we also see wang is
actually helping her interrogate
abomination and then we see some shots
of some mystery sorcerers one with a
like a fuchsia glowing mace and some
other it looks like it could be like
dark dimension powered sorcery uh
artifacts um i
i first off we gotta talk about wong's
relationship with abomination uh in
shanxi
and is this going to be i don't know if
it's set before shanxi but are we gonna
get some reference to like what they
were doing in the golden daggers club
yeah i feel like um
she-hulk might take place during the
blip
and that you know
like we're going to see like how
wong had a relationship with abomination
and like how they met sort of through
she-hulk and like shang-chi probably
takes place after she-hulk um in my
opinion oh that's interesting but like
the glowing purple mace like i sort of
got like pandestine vibes from that even
because like we just got them introduced
in this marvel and we heard that the the
red daggers were fighting the clinton
distance for a while so like we could
see more clandestines popping up in
shield
interesting yeah i guess we don't know
how many total clandestines there are or
if it's not the clandestines just uh
exiles from some other dimension that
has had an incursion with this dimension
you know yeah you know and that question
of i
i would just be really surprised if
marvel sets any of their phase four or
beyond titles during the blip it just
seems like with every time that we've
speculated that they're always like no
it's just that after yeah i think you
just want to keep moving it forward
because i think they're afraid to set
things during the blip even though that
would actually make things easier for a
lot of their stories you know right um i
think enough things could be set during
the blip uh it's just at that point why
would they
you would think that they would just
reveal that uh right in their marketing
like i don't know why they and also i
think the fact that la just looks so
clean and the fact that like san
francisco looked like
complete garbage mad max universe when
scott lang was running through it
i think anytime like society looks okay
it's implied that this is after the blip
and things have kind of returned to the
status quo a bit true like during the
blip especially like right after um like
the five years later like the the color
grading was just so dim and like so
everything's sad
yeah so before before you
non-californians say well isn't san
francisco a [ __ ] anyway no i live in
san francisco and the media you have
heard that san francisco is covered in
trash and garbage and whatever it's uh
wrong i live here the parks are clean
it's beautiful it's expensive it's way
too expensive for any normal human being
to live here but there's a reason why
you get what you pay for it's a lovely
place to live and i lived in los angeles
for 12 years before that and yes there's
far more trash on the streets of los
angeles i love both cities i don't want
to dis either city i'm just saying that
you know your grandparents in the
midwest who tell you that uh the cities
in california are on fire and they're
going to hell
let up think that because it's actually
really nice to live here
talking trash
just literally expensive
um anyway but let's talk about how wong
mentions the book of ashanti he says
that we
answer to a higher power and then he
uses the book of ashanti it's kind of
like his constitution that he follows
you know and it's a book of positive
spells that counteracts the dark hold
but the darkhold and the book of ashanti
are now
destroyed right right so i wonder do you
think that could have had an effect on
now the mcu broadly if if we assume
she-hill takes place after multiverse of
madness um do you think that the
those books being gone could have been
leading to some of these supernatural
incursions and could be leading to all
these like weird alternate
realm beings now running amok that that
jennifer walters has to deal with i
could definitely see that being a
possibility for sure like the book of
ashanti's destruction i feel like is a
bigger deal
than um they covered in multiverse of
madness so i feel like like multiverse
man has set up potentially something
bigger to happen because of the book's
destruction so i feel like that's
definitely a possibility there for sure
but again like i definitely also feel
like this is this takes place during the
blip and like you know the book of
ashanti hasn't been destroyed yet which
is why wong is like yeah book of ashanti
that's totally fine um i think about
that all the time um so
yeah i feel like
it's probably said during the blip but i
don't know i don't know it could this
could very well be um like all the weird
stuff in the mcu could very well be
happening because of the destruction of
the book of ashaki yeah i i think we're
the fact that wong is in this and he's
like worried about these incursions i
think the idea is that like this is just
another example we're gonna i don't
think we're gonna see like a major
explanation of the multiversal crisis
that we're in uh
because like i think phase four they're
just like not really committing to any
of that yet they will see more of that
in like quantum mania and beyond right
but uh i i do think this is going to be
said after multiverse of madness and i
think the fact that he mentions book of
ashanti i think that's what
i i think it's going to be like the dark
hold has gone or like they'll have some
other kind of like vague language for
why demons and goblins and vampires and
[ __ ] are running around um and we
actually see some of these in this next
detail uh detail 17. uh lots of like
wizards people with suped up tech and
then there's this goblin looking beast
that i thought was like a werewolf they
kind of reminded me of like the uh the
jackals and moon knight that are running
across which we still don't really know
the jackals come from some like purple
colored realm that we as soon as the
underworld right but i think that's
another realm it's another dimension and
uh specifically the details the fact
that part of its head has these like
horns or whatever that have turned black
and the way the gradient
looks it looks a lot like the dark holes
effect on the fingertips of wanda and
agatha in 838 strange so do you think
this being well what do you think it is
first of all do you think it could be
some kind of
spawn of the dark hold being destroyed
no um i feel like this could definitely
be like a dark world-esque beast like a
like a beast of darkness but also could
be um like one of those like gamma
radiated dogs remember from the first
hulk film um
where he punched it in the ball yeah
like those weird like hulked out dogs
like i would love to see like a hulked
out like beast that'd be so fun um but
yeah no i can definitely see this being
a dark world creature where like the
same type of like realm where those um
weird jackals came from at moonlight for
sure i just love to finally get some
answers on like just name these things i
love that ms marvel named it the nord
dimension like just start to give us
names like call it anything i don't care
right okay just a little detail i want
to point out i love when hulk punches
she-hulk off the ledge she flips them
off and they blur it out like we have to
blur that out whatever
i guess for the for the kitties um but i
just love how he punches her off screen
looking at a lot like when hulk punched
thor on a freaking avengers in in grand
central station he's jealous that dude
is jealous
he's jealous he doesn't want anyone else
to get the attention um okay the final
shot after the title shows jen meeting
daredevil as he flips over her head he's
got his batons and he has this red and
gold suit it actually looks more like
his original appearance to the comics
and he's like red and yellow before he
evolved into his more iconic all red
suit or the red and black looks um do
you think jen and matt murdock will team
up legally or face off legally or is it
just going to be like
daredevil makes an appearance as like
one of her clients like a vigilante that
she has to represent or deal with and
really the more the legal stuff's going
to be in the born-again series with
kingpin i feel like jen and matt
are going to be teaming up legally
because we saw in a no way home that
matt was like one of the first people to
show up to the super beings peter
parker's door it's like hey let me uh
represent you because like that's what i
do um so i feel like um jen and matt are
gonna be friends in and out of the suit
well you know not in that way but like
you know maybe who
knows but uh yeah no um i feel like
they're definitely gonna be uh close
friends i hope so i i just wanna see him
in action as an attorney again at least
at some point the fact that we're seeing
him you know in the suit with the batons
awesome very cool but like and based on
the tone of the show i don't know how
violent he can get so i'm just kind of
more excited to see his legal acumen and
right how brilliant he is in a courtroom
um true now the final detail is she now
in the shot has her more comic accurate
spandex suit suggesting this is gonna be
later in the season um but we had this
interesting line from the beginning of
the trailer where hulk says spandex is
your friend i think there might be some
kind of like thematic underpinning to
that like something that can stretch
something that can be flexible uh and
just kind of roll with the punches and
evolve with you as you grow is your
friend and i'm curious how do you think
she will get her her suit who's gonna
hook her up with the suit is she gonna
make it herself i think it's gonna be
the hulk that makes her suit because
like it is like you said it's spandex
and like it's very much like
specifically made for her power set and
i feel like the person that knows her
best in her power set is bruce banner
because he's been working with her for
so long but uh it could be anyone what
do you think i think it's rinsha
[Laughter]
i think richard's gonna come in there
and make her suit it's def it's been
it's richard confirmed at this point
or maybe we meet
maybe we meet melvin potter you know
like if dirty's in here why not melvin
potter too get you know like that'd be
fun to that's him hey like melvin made
daredevil suits why not right but it
does kind of have that spandexy design
of uh reed richard's suit from
multiverse of madness so i don't know
maybe
838 christine palmer shows up
i got nothing to do
my players are dead
i've just been selling this whole time
we will leave it there for this episode
of inside marvel i can't wait to react
to this show every week with you until
you think about you it's gonna be so
much fun be sure to follow mt at
mastertainment uh you can follow me at
eavos uh subscribe to inside marvel
wherever you get your podcast subscribe
to new rockstars here on youtube thank
you so much for watching and we'll see
you next time bye everybody let's go bye
you